I have a dream Saul to see I'm so glad  you're here  I'm pregnant but I don't know how to do  this by myself  your mother is the greatest person we  ever made baby  let me tell you how she did it all on  her own  [Music]  life is short the world is wide  I want to make some memories  this dress might look very pretty on you  you don't know me at all do you  [Music]  I think we should stay here together I  wish I could stay it turns out he's  engaged I hate it when they do that I  was cheated by you I think you know when  look at me now will I ever learn I don't  know how but I suddenly lose control  there's a fire within my soul Arabella  never felt closer to my mom she wasn't  scared because she had me  here I go again  we can't tell anybody else about the  baby okay  I just told bill and I told Harry I told  many many people let's get the party  started grandma you aren't invited  that's the best kind of party little  girl  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]